this move I'm about to try is a very
risky play and they grabbed me by my
neck like this so I just got called out
for being a liar so I kind of messed
that up
I'm really hoping Aria doesn't yell at
me it's all my friends know I'm very
very sorry
already well this has been one hell of a
vacation
hi there I'm Aria and I've had quite a
bit of a year so I definitely need a
holiday but I'd also like to not lose
any vacation days at work so with the
trend of youtubers tricking their
Instagram followers with fake trips I
want to flip that on its head by seeing
if I can fake being at work while
actually on holiday for a week my
Instagram following is not quite as
large as these influencers so the goal
here is to primarily convince the people
I actually know that I'm still in Los
Angeles while I'm actually abroad for
this challenge I'm aiming to post at
least two pictures on my feet during the
week at least two stories a day and I
can't have more than three people
suspect me of lying by the end of it
okay so I'm here at BuzzFeed with my
buddy Jack two weeks before my actual
trip because we're gonna spend the whole
day today taking the photos and stories
that I'll need to post while I'm on my
little hiatus I have a lot of doubts
anyone that you know and see on a
day-to-day basis I think they're gonna
know that you're not at your desk or not
at work can you get in trouble for this
to assist me on this challenge I wrote
bin maro
Merle's job while I'm gone is to be my
inside woman at BuzzFeed providing
content to assist me in pulling this off
I think we could do it oh you're you're
you're just gonna take full credit for
it I mean I'm your strongest asset at
this point do you have a boss here who's
you're higher up do they know I'm here
in Rome it isn't 1 p.m. and today's the
first day I'm supposed to be back in the
office today I'm gonna post a video of
me driving to work and then Merle is
supposed to post a story that we took
before I left make it seem as if I'm in
the office so I kind of messed that up
I left a calendar reminder in my own
calendar last night to wear the black
dress and I'm wearing a Mickey Mouse
shirt and sweat pants I'm not posting
the video today because I think it's a
risk sorry aria so the plan is already
changed on day one I'm going to be
posting what I was supposed to post
tomorrow today for the first day I
decide to post a series of stories near
the office with PD plastic an actor and
rapper i've previously hired off of
craigslist on numerous occasions thank
you for coming PD how things been for
you I've been pretty good recently
honestly I got like dang
Vegas like three weeks ago four weeks
ago excuse me is that PT plastic I see
over there
PT plastic Keaney excuse me sir are you
international rap superstar PT plastic
oh yes I am
that's good I felt natural so I didn't
start off as strong as I had hoped in
this challenge but I have redeemed
myself because I checked are you in
because class Acharya left his badge at
home which he does all the time
believable trust me and I said he's
going to visit Megan so Megan is gonna
get a notification that aria is here I
have a photo in my phone so when it
asked me to take a picture after I send
in under Aria I held the photo up and I
got this Jim so Megan will know that
Aria or Gollum from the Lord of the
Rings is here to visit and all is well
in the world and he's back I'm feeling
more confident than ever
mostly myself mildly intoxicated right
now in Rome we're gonna do tequila shots
so far so good I don't think anyone
suspects anything okay this is the end
of my vlog
I'm not too hungover I was and now I
think I'm fine I mean was the coffee I
did it the important questions that
needed to be answered so I just posted
the video Terraria of him drawing in a
horribly insulting portrait of me I
posted to my Instagram I'm wearing the
outfit from the video so I think yeah
our plans right back on track on my end
I'm doing everything to a tee so I kind
of messed that off it doesn't work you
can't believe on me is what I'm trying
to say so I kind of messed that up in
addition to sharing a moral story I also
throw up a quick poll on Instagram we
had staged in the BuzzFeed canteen the
BuzzFeed logo in there a little bit I
will say that things are getting a
little hairy right now I've received
messages from several people asking if
I'm in the office and why I'm not coming
to see them specifically my dear friend
and fellow producer Meghan I'm feel bad
because Megan was out of the office for
a little while I told her I would see
her this week when I got back to the
offense and I've get that stopped by her
desk so I'm sure right now I'm making
things I'm a bit of an [ __ ]
all my friends and co-workers at work
that are watching this now know I'm very
very sorry
buongiorno
I will say I'm loving Rome and whenever
I seem to yell buongiorno
one day on Saturday I make my way to be
a Multi coast but the weekend still
presents its fair share of challenges
now that it's the weekend I've already
received messages from friends that want
to hang out and so now I have to find a
way to talk my way out of those plans by
making up other plans I think that makes
it a little trickier at the fact that
this isn't just a regular weekend it's a
long weekend today what I'm posting is
Jack and I filmed a segment before I
left where we went to get ice cream
together so I'm gonna throw that up as a
poll for the audience issues when I
order my friend Nando wants to hang out
this weekend but what I'm going to do is
I'm going to message Nando and actually
invite him to come to the ice cream shop
with us the Nando is very notorious for
being late so I'm thinking I'm going to
invite him with very very short notice
I'm gonna give him maybe a 20-minute
heads-up and I'm hoping that he sticks
true to fashion and is unable to make it
it's a risky move because if he does
actually say oh I'll meet you guys there
that I don't know what I'm gonna do I
messaged Fernando inviting him to get
ice cream of Jack and I first Fernando
questioned why I'm getting ice cream so
early in the morning Fernando then
decided to complain about the fact that
I have made plans to hang out with Jack
despite not seeing him yet and ignoring
him all week so yet another person that
thinks I'm an [ __ ] I'm a captain I
don't forget that maybe we can get a
drink later I feel that's a very
dangerous thing to say cuz it definitely
seems like you won't have a drink with
him like later well I'm about to go to
bed right now it's the end of day 3 I
just posted a photo that Jack took of me
so hopefully people believe I'm still in
LA it's gonna be a little tricky now
because Fernando kind of expects me to
hang out with him tonight I guess it's a
night for him it's gonna be one sleeping
here and leave hopefully I don't wake up
to a bunch of messages well turns out
Nando decided to have a night ever
lucky me I'm definitely a little
stressed because a bunch of my friends
are supposed to be hanging out today and
I'm telling them I can't go because I'm
going to a Ringo Starr concert there's
no the concert going out tonight so it
works out perfectly I need two previous
people that I'm
the one of us just can't Wingo with you
go Rango Rango Rango Rango
Ringo a part of this is fun but I also
feel pretty bad lying so profusely we're
gonna walk back air babe you know and
then I have to wake up at 5:00 a.m. to
close my stories all right they're
supposed to the stories of my brother
and I at the Ringo Starr concert as fun
as this whole challenge has been at
times you know waking up at 5:00 a.m. on
holiday probably is the best way to
spend a vacation so moving forward I'm
just now gonna be more cognizant of the
fact that I am on holiday and just not
let this challenge disrupt it too much
more I think my stories last nights into
work the only things I'm posting today
is something to my close friends list
the close friends feature on Instagram
is one where you can only have to select
people view your stories so this is my
first time using the close friends
feature I've added all my friends and
co-workers to my close friends list and
I'm gonna post a story that was shot at
my apartment so hopefully they just
think that I'm home today okay so I find
myself in a very very interesting
predicament because this man this older
fellow keep sending me pictures of his
genitals I block one account sends him
again under a different one I blocked
that one he says it again I'm a
different one I'm mildly intoxicated
right now I've keep receiving messages
from people my close friends list
suggesting what I do with these nudes I
keep receiving I feel a bit bad it is
Tuesday which means that all my friends
and co-workers are getting back into the
office today
so as an excuse for me not being in the
office most of the day today
I'm there
people that I employ off-site to film an
interview with Elaine a woman that was
captured by baboons for twenty nine days
to help me stage a fake video shoot I
hire Elaine balance an actress I've
found on Craigslist I'm thinking you
know we just get you in front of a chair
and you just tell us a harrowing story
about how you were captured by baboons
for 29 days I was there with the baboons
and let me tell you this day is definite
risky because the whole story of the
lane being captured by that moon for 29
days is kind of ridiculous and so
hopefully some of my more savvy or
coworkers or friends don't find it too
suspicious pairing this is horrible ties
a little bit but I I couldn't believe it
I thought oh my gosh I spent all my
money my life savings what's gonna
happen to me hopefully people believe
aliens acting and they grabbed me by my
neck like this I will say that before I
went to bed last night I posted a story
saying I was gonna film this video with
Elaine and I asked my followers for any
questions they may have come up with
very vague answers that I could just
throw in and I actually got a fair
number of responses from my followers
including several of my co-workers I
knew who they were their names and gave
me a couple yeses in a couple of noes
yes ha no definitely no yeah well I was
in Mozambique in Africa you know baboons
only live in Africa Arabia and I took
the safari in Africa however before I
can celebrate too much I receive an
unfortunate message so I'm about to go
to bed and I just received a message
from one of my friends Adriana and she
accuses me of being a liar
I think everyone just thinks she's a
very eccentric woman but Adriana see if
they think something is up and that's a
little worrying because they drown it
may talked about it with some of my
other friends and then if they start
putting two of the two together this
could all go down in flames
apparently Adriana googled this story
and she's questioning why there's
nothing on Google or on all about Elaine
which is a very valid point I think what
I decide I'm gonna do is I'm going to
tell Adriana that I'm making a video
about disseminating fake news how easy
it is to make up stories online and see
if you don't believe it I last way to
keep quiet and hopefully she will
hopefully she's the only person that
thinks about googling this woman I have
two days left on my trip and I am
celebrating not just because I'm in
beautiful Amsterdam but because I was
able to convince Adriana to keep quiet
about her suspicions no one seems to
suspect that I am not in LA right now I
have two days left to pull this off
throughout the week I continue to
receive messages from friends and
co-workers asking for me which continues
to make this challenge quite difficult
it's Wednesday which means we get free
catered meals at BuzzFeed and so the
plan is for Merle to make me a plate at
work and then take a picture of it for
me to post on my story friends have
already expressed their displeasure at
the fact that I seem to be actively
avoiding them this is yet another day
where I'm supposedly in the office and
not seeing them so I'm gonna have to
find a way to dance around that it's all
a risk at this point all right I just
got Aria his lunch I took a photo of the
lunch originally he asked me if I would
put meat on my plate I am vegan and I
said no I will not put meat on your
plate because I'm gonna eat this food
after I take a photo of it looks like
our he's going plant based on the old
Instagram that's very trendy these days
anyway so
good for you aria so we're gonna take a
photo here at this green wall because a
lot of buzz feeders they love to abuse
this wall before I go to bed I'll post
up the pictures Jack took with me from
the green wall but I'm gonna say that
Merle took the photos I think everybody
employed that I follow has taken at
least one photo with this wall I have
yet to do so until today that's 4 a.m.
and my alarm has just gone off so I can
post the story of me at defiant Jim okay
I need your shoutout to define Jim
always a crazy workout here if you need
a place to Train my tie this is the
place at this very moment I won't lie
I'm very much looking forward this
challenge being over I actually don't
enjoy lying quite as much as I thought I
would have Nando and I have already made
plans to hang out tomorrow but I guess
he doesn't know that some car trouble
isn't coming for my final day of posting
in order to get out of plans at work and
with friends I bring in Roy Allen
another actor I've hired off of
Craigslist my car is for lack of a
better word it's quite beaten up it's
quite rundown I must have gotten that
off Craigslist - what we do have here is
we have a smoke grenade the smoke
grenade will only be able to be used
once so we have one take with a smoke
grenade we're gonna put it near the hood
and we're gonna add it kind of just
smoke I'm gonna snap a couple of videos
from my phone and it'll hopefully look
like the car smoking and then at some
point you'll come by and we'll film you
fixing it this talk improvised what in
the world did you do to this thing good
heaven looks like it hasn't been
maintained in at least five years yes
keep using your acting skills in heaven
alright everyone I am okay the smokey
stopped this nice gentleman here he came
by made the smoking stop somehow okay
and it's just been a few minutes since I
posted the story and I've already
received a whole bunch of messages from
people concerned about my car situation
and I do feel very bad as the night
progresses my phone continues to blow up
with concern messages from friends I got
missed these times and that's just from
some of my friends I didn't feel very
bad right now about causing this whole
commotion with my story I think the
difference is that when other youtubers
or my co-workers have done this lying to
their followers there's a different
dynamic than when you're lying
specifically towards people you know
especially your friends who are invested
in your emotional well-being and
something I didn't really think about or
take into consideration before this I
really feel bad that I'm making them
worry luckily for me though it's the
final night of the challenge and the
next day I fly back to Los Angeles but
not before making a quick pit stop at
the office on my way home
it is currently 5:45 so I've made it
into the office before 6:00 p.m. on
Friday itself because I've been in
Europe Abbadon Europe
what what let's see no you haven't
no I saw your work posting on holiday
was not the hard part
I think lying to people was the hardest
part especially people I knew that boon
lady fake car accident fake car smoke
grenade mmm yeah crazy man
that man was I hired him off of
Craigslist you're you're a psychopath
big girl no brownie oh yeah there's been
a success and I'd like to say that it is
in in large part because of me and my
efforts she should be just as angry with
morale honestly if not more so more
angry with her than me I bought them all
souvenirs though so hopefully hopefully
they can forgive me see you
overall this was a fantastic trip what I
do this challenge again no I feel bad
about having lied to so many people but
we managed to pull it off
I got Fernando a Dutch gay magazine it
was very thoughtful look at those
beautiful uncut man I need more hair
they're quite shame these they're all
shades I don't understand are they
mostly circumcised or uncircumcised this
big and this is Europe so they were all
gonna be on cut
[Music]